our next speaker
never actually was a real Harbormaster
that's how he goes by social media and
that becomes from that comes from a
deep-seated desire to become a
Harbormaster when he retires
so please welcome Bob
I hope everyone's enjoying the New York
archive this is my first New York Bar
conference it's an amazing conference
you've all been amazing the speakers
have been amazing um it's glad to be
here
to one important thing one not so
important thing before we begin this is
about webar I have put spiders inside
there's actually one on this one that's
really tiny uh inside the presentation
and I know that Arachnophobia is a legit
thing I'm not making fun of it so if
anyone does not do well with spiders you
might want to skip this and the second
one is
um 20 minutes is not enough time for me
to bother with the bio if you don't know
me this is me online everywhere
um I've got a lot of our packages and if
there's time for a bio at the end I will
be glad to talk a little bit more about
that but web R is more important than I
am
so you're here for Into the Web rverse
if this is not your flight please see
this flight attendant back and they'll
get you to the right one I'm going to
try to help on me you understand how to
bring the power of R to the browser and
beyond my two goals for this talk I mean
there's one overarching goal which will
not happen which is you walk quit your
jobs and do web R after this and just
proselytize that the more achievable one
I think is hopefully everyone that is an
R person here will poke at webar and use
webar in some way shape or form sometime
after this hopefully within the next
year
uh so let's map out where we're going to
go today with this one so the first
thing we're going to talk about are
foundations uh so it's I like to think
of this as wasm 101 how many people know
what webassembly is or wasm
cool how many people have used wasm
being like them deliberately like you've
created something in wasm
cool you're not gonna have to do that
with web bar but I just want to see how
technical so this is good so we will
spend a little bit more time on that
that was going to do like every great
superhero we're going to talk about the
origin story of web R and also the
challenges that were involved in some of
that uh so now that you're going to
learn about that great power we're going
to learn what you can do with that great
power and then we're gonna maybe step
away from our land for a little bit to
talk about what you can do with webar
outside of traditional art contexts and
then we're going to show you how to dive
into the web art verse on your own so
you can go out there and start doing a
lot of great stuff with it
so webassembly uh it's also short named
wasm this is something that was built in
2015 it's been people were poking at it
for a while and the fancy description of
it is it's a binary instruction format
targeting a stack based virtual machine
that runs in browser or on system uh
we'll talk about what that means in more
context and a little bit that fancy
thing it basically just means your bike
have a binary blob of something and it
runs in kind of a virtual machine
this is wasm that's this isn't actually
binary code obviously it's asking that
you can all read it looks a little bit
like assembler code it's a little bit
easier to write I think than assembler
code and you can actually write in this
I find it adorable that they made an
acronym for it called watt because like
that's from the old what days but uh you
can write straight core wasm one of my
teammates where I work can write and
like is very prolific and very like uh
just proficient in writing pure awesom
but you don't have to do this there are
lots of things out there that make it
possible to go do this
um and you can use a lot of languages
right now to create wasm targets and the
first and coolest ones I think because
I'm I've you see for like most of my
life uh CNC plus plus has a tool and
ecosystem called inscriptin so in
scripting is something is an llvm to
JavaScript webassembly compiler lovm
sort of sits in between the compilation
step and where executable code is
created in some ecosystems that are out
there uh what this what a scripting lets
you do is write C code and then it just
spits out the code that you can use that
code those functions inside JavaScript
it's kind of cool you can get really
efficient code and we'll talk about that
in a second rust maybe my second
favorite language to R it's not actually
that's not true it's third Small Talk R
and then rust uh it has llvm as a
background already or or as a back end
it's actually a lot easier I think to
write rust code that works in
webassembly than C I'm just a little
biased because I am a pretty big
artificial I rest Aficionado and go
another language that I use at work have
to but I also kind of like has
experimental support for it as well and
it's still experimental even now even
though it's been around for a while so
lots of modern cool useful languages are
plugging plugging themselves into web
assembly it's really kind of neat seeing
all those things and there's lots more
so this is a link the slides links are
going to be like available here they're
also at the end of this I've already
posted it on social media so you can get
there so most of this is a go see other
things and learn a bunch of cool stuff
talk
why am I talking about wasm why does
webar use was and why like what's up
with this whole thing
um well it gives you in browser and on
system we're not going to talk about the
on system stuff at all today finally
after this I will go on forever about
that near native execution speed why is
that important well JavaScript it's not
slow there's no I think you could call
JavaScript slow at all in any modern
context but JavaScript isn't as fast as
actually running at near native speed
this kind of gets you wasm almost the
speed of running executable code on any
endpoint that you're running in a
browser it's not perfect it's not
exactly but it's really close and a lot
closer than native JavaScript
and it's been designed with safety in
mind so if we go back a couple slides
and I made that foofy definition of what
this stuff is it probably summoned to
you like wait a minute there's this
thing running binary Blobs of code in a
browser context that sounds an awful
like flash wasn't flash a disaster yeah
flash was an absolute disaster I am
sorry if you like playing all those
fancy games in Flash that did all sorts
of things it was a it brought havoc in
from a safety perspective I do cyber
security for a living
um so I I'm the guy that makes your days
miserable because I always throw I toss
water on all the joy you have online but
um it's back flash is back thanks to
wasm all the flash games are coming back
for me all the flash visual all the
stuff that was made visualization wise
so back in the day Volks may not
remember this but a lot of newspapers
and a lot of other online like like
universities and just online researchers
were making amazing cool Cutting Edge
visualizations in Flash they all went
away because Flash went away from every
browser you can't run them we love like
a decade worth of really cool work wasm
is bringing that back for us it's really
kind of cool and so you might have also
thought if you if you weren't flash
years wait a minute there's this VM
running in a browser that runs binary
blobs and stuff aren't those those
horrible Java applets and yeah it's like
those terrible Java applets with the
worst user experience in the world and
they're also back too so for everyone
that works in an Enterprise yeah you're
gonna have some terrible third-party
Enterprise organization making a job
applet that resurrecting it from the
zombie grave as you're going to see that
is it's not me it's them don't do that
now and like it nobody wants to add more
Java than anybody's saying anyway wants
to have more Java code to the universe
so if anything care about wasm so we
don't have to talk about Java anymore
um but this gives us entirely new ways
to create
um all sorts of in-browser experiences
and applications and it also lets us do
stuff at the edge it's a fancy term for
like running stuff like on the perimeter
of the internet again no time to talk
about that today find me up and I'll be
glad to talk about that in detail
um so I'm going to go over here this is
our
I'm not sure how much you can see this
is actually our running in a quarto so
you heard about quarto before how many
people use Cordo
more of you should be raising your hands
use quarter okay so this is using uh in
Cordo uh this is an R environment this
is an actual R thing and I'm going to
prove it to you this the demo guys be
with me
I just ran our code in the browser you
can see what the session information is
wasm32 blah blah blah blah
um so you don't I could have make made
that up so I'm going to paste what I had
on my clipboard
and I didn't I pasted too wrong in the
clipboard so let me do that and do it
again that I just proved that it's
actually running something so I just ran
some really old tired not tidy models
you know like uh sorry because old
school are
um stuffins are in browser not not no
shiny server required no magic no
sending it to an API anywhere oh I'm
running here if I if I turn the internet
off turn the network off it would still
run it's kind of amazing
so why is that amazing so it works on
Chromebooks horrible I hate Chromebooks
it runs on those icky window systems
Jared too uh it doesn't require a shiny
server if you know me you know that's to
me a really good thing uh it provides a
robust Graphics device because our has
that cool graphics device capability
there's a great graphics device for it
now that's been built by the creators
who we'll talk about in a second which
means I get to put ggplot2 in the
browser without having to like you have
execute code somewhere else it's modern
R it's based on r4.1 and it will
continue to work with r moving forward
you're not just executing those chunky
code blocks like I showed I'll talk
about in a second it's all in browser
and you could even if you like jupyter
notebooks I'm not one of those like I'm
on the left side of that do you hate
Jupiter notebooks or like them I am on
the hate despise never exist stupid
General exciting
um but more exciting for me than that
anything is I like to do stats and all
that kind of work in R and now I get to
do that in R and give JavaScript the
results this is great it makes a whole
new generation of web apps possible and
I'm really excited about it so like I
said everything has an origin every good
superhero has a great origin story so
this one is George stag and Lionel
Hammer you might know Lionel from
rstudio George is also our studio or
sorry posit I still can't do that it's
pause it now uh just clarification on
here so like I did not ask them if I
could run their uh image their images
through some fancy AI thing online
that's going to steal their image and
give me a cartoon back so this is a 15
year old image magic script that did a
pretty decent job with no AI involved so
I just wanted to give a shout out to
image back it's pretty cool so you might
have seen that web R came out this year
around March 0.1.0 was published but
that is not the origin of webr the
origin web R goes way back to 2022 when
if you were stalking George like I was
you saw him in his own repo not this one
uh create something like called Web R
like what's going on here I want to see
this
so four directories seven files he
managed to work a miracle he actually
got R ported over to wasm so it was
runnable in that context now you're
saying wait a minute you just told me
all this stuff was like the C and there
is an RC like you just recompile it
should just work and you're right so I
stole this from George's presentation
you should be able to take those C files
put them through a configure statement
get the stuff out and boom you're
available you know it's all done make a
lot of money go on vacation drink a lot
of beers that's great this this is what
it should be like and but you know I
think everybody that knows that uses our
might know this but we use a lot of
Fortran when we use Zara and that means
like blast and le pack and lots of other
things that are out there also a lot of
packages are compiled packages that are
based on C or C plus plus or even
outgoing or Fortran or rust R is
probably the best language for wrapping
something some other languages binary
code into it to be able to use it I say
that having used lots of things over the
course of my very long Lifetime and I'm
a little biased about how awesome ours
in this particular case but because of
this complexity
it's really frustrating it's just a
royal pain it's it's actually a maze of
twisty little passive passages for
everyone that used to play Zork as a kid
or as an adult
um it takes a lot of effort to get R
working in a wasm context it's just it
is phenomenal and between George and
Lionel and a bunch of other people that
have contributed to it who have
literally pulled their hair out at times
try to make this work and get it working
in this environment they've managed to
do it in a repeatable way this is really
exciting they have done so much hard
work and we have so much to be thankful
for specifically George but George and
Lionel now I I owe them personally a
data gratitude but I think we all do as
well so we have all this power now we
have R anywhere without a server
what are you going to do with this power
I I'm not going to repeat the tagline
that you've heard way too many times in
every Super uh every Spider-Man origin
story movie ever made by Marvel
uh so you have great power this is how
easy it is to use this great power so
um this is this is Javascript file and
what I'm doing in this Javascript file
it's not super important to go through
it in a lot of detail but that import
line is basically what you would type
maybe there'd be a URL instead of just
like r wasm that gives you all of web R
and those next couple lines make are
available every single place in
JavaScript in your HTML file
that is all you have to do to start
using web R now I've done some fun stuff
with that I've made a bunch of I've been
playing with web R for a while now so
I've got some helper functions but in
this particular one hopefully anyone
here can read the r cut on this one
which is I'm basically just making a
date sequence that's all I'm doing here
on ours so that's going to create a
character a date Vector in R then it's
going to turn into a character vector by
just using that R code with that little
r and that you know the the brackets
thing I have now made all of that R data
available to JavaScript and that console
log is basically going to print out the
JavaScript array from the r character
vector and this is a toy example but
this is literally all you have to do to
make stuff available from R to
JavaScript so you can run all sorts of
fancy cool statistical stuff on there
you can run machine learning stuff on
there you could do amazing stuff with R
feed it all back to JavaScript so we
could do other things with it to present
it to the user and I'm going to show you
some of those later but this is
literally how simple it is but if that's
still too complex for you James Bellamy
to uh coat list on Twitter and
everywhere else coatless Professor one
of the coolest humans if you ever get a
chance to meet James is one of the
coolest humans on the planet he actually
made it even simpler so that little demo
that I showed you before was actually
his Cordo version of web R so he
basically made it so you do this all
right there's a little button right here
I can do it yeah you mean you do this
little web R chunk and it fires up the
web R and stancia does all the work I
just showed you how to do in the
JavaScript and you get to do anything
with that in there and I was able to
type in that code block but you could
have it run this stuff make ggplots
throw HTML widgets up whatever you want
to go do and he's made it super easy to
start working in Cordo and web R so if
you weren't if you want believer in
Corridor before you really should be now
because it's going to make your life a
lot easier when you build some things
um and there are now about 200 pre-built
webar packages which is double from what
it was when it first came out and most
of you that because I I will ask someone
here has to know the answer because
there's got to be crayon aficionados
here how many packages does this cran
have somebody
come on somebody John I'm going to Big
like you if you don't
yeah so yeah there's like 18 or 19 000
packets nearly 20 000 on crayon 200 is a
really really small things so like I
mentioned before a lot of those are like
compiled packages it's really rough to
do that still so we're in a nascent
stage but the Tidy verse is available so
for everyone that wants to do tidy verse
in their GG plots available a bunch of
really cool things and useful things are
there I've been following what they're
porting over to their tidy models is
right there now are going to be there
soon so things that you're familiar with
in modern art are actually there now
um are how many people are familiar with
our universe
oh so definitely click that link when
you get there later because I can't talk
about it uh our up inside in your room
have made this amazing thing which is
not cram I kind of don't take this bad
crayon folks I kind of want cran to die
in the fire
um uh but there's reasons talk to me
later I'd be glad to opine about it um
our universe is like gonna be the new
crayon it's amazing uh they're gonna
pre-build wasm packages as well too for
us so we don't have to deal with a lot
of these things but what the cool thing
is even though they haven't even though
they haven't made or compiled a bunch of
even base our packages for it any base r
package right now can be used in web R
and I've got stuff online that show you
how to do that so there's a lot of just
purebase R packages even with
dependencies out there so they're all
available right now so it goes beyond
those 200.
so this is what you can do with it you
have all this power but you're going to
use this power in a new way you're going
to use this power in the web
uh so I'm going to purport that but I
like a show of hands as I read through
these how many people know markdown in
some form figured cool I'm people who
know HTML CSS some way shape or form
very cool and at least a little
JavaScript cool because most of us have
cut and pasted script tags from stack
Overflow to try to make something work
in something that we couldn't do before
this is great you're all set up to use
web R I'm really serious about this
um so you have great part of your
fingertips and you're gonna hate this I
hate this the browser is the future of
data science
I'm really sorry I mean I know it's not
for large language models because they
need
large amounts of like
um environment killing compute to be
able to do what they do but the browser
is going to be where most of us do our
work moving forward and where a lot of
the people that we need to teach for the
next generation and what they have is
going to do that too so you cannot let
this power be co-opted by people that
say you should use vue.js or you should
use like any one of the cool Frameworks
out there you should just build stuff in
x
When someone tells you to do it this way
now that you have freedom it'll at the
very least constrains you and if you've
seen the movie that I've been basing
this on it doesn't go well if they tell
you what to do because you end up having
to fight a bunch of things at the end
and it just it's a bad day it's really a
bad day
so I'm gonna so I'm challenging everyone
here learn HTML CSS JS more than you
have now this is a great place to start
links everywhere on the slides to go
forward
Mozilla developer Network their guides
are amazing you should go there for that
as well as is w3schools great places
just keep in your browser tabs they're
they'll be indispensable references and
teach you everything you need to know
learn modern tooling uh so I talked
about like ice glitch is a cool modern
environment talk to me later about why
it is basically doesn't touch a server
at all runs everything in the browser
the entire JS development all in browser
node.js web server everything Rebel it's
getting close to that too both great
environments I'm going to tell you to
use something like vs code or one of the
non-skeezy versions of it but if you
like neovim or Sublime Text or some
newer ones they're also kind of getting
up to par on some of these things
uh so I like it hit up the mothership
with a minute and 38 seconds left
mothership is web R I will try to make a
little bigger for you go there for
everything it's now at 01.2 with 0.1
before it's kind of cool
um this is also their their this is
their version of the r console that's
running inside there so you can actually
play with r and a graphics environment
right there
um check out my webinar experiment so
I've been going crazy about this thing
so for a while this year I just did a
lot of things to give people a lot of
ways to go do this kind of stuff
one is I built an entire online IDE
that's very vs code ask or rstudio asked
if you if you use our studio it's got
all the kind of bells and whistles there
online help and everything looks a lot
more like you would use rstudio than it
would be for that other one that's out
there I also have an example of showing
how to use this how many people have
heard of observable
uh it's like cold it's like D3 they have
a plot Library that's also not
associated with observable directly this
is our feeding random sample data to D3
um plot libraries out there dynamically
updating charts within there are are
doing all the work for the data JS doing
all the work for the visualizations lots
of really cool things that you can do
out there with this that you just could
not do before in an easy way
the
start with Cordo uh basically like it's
knitting a quarter document with our
code in it everyone here can do that
monitor the webar topic that's on GitHub
or any one of your other favorite social
coding sites I also have links to all
these in here there's already an I'll
cut there's an awesome list for
everything there's an awesome list for
web R2 please make stuff with Web Bar
because like this isn't hubris but like
I'm the only one building stuff with Web
Bar it seems so like I'm kind of in
there a lot so I need company so please
go I don't run the list but it's just
there watch what our universe is doing
because you're going to find all the
packages there
um look at so I have to see something
else about python in a couple seconds oh
I'm done but piadite is python beat is
there let's beat them rust is there go
is there and there's all sorts of other
things that you can do please hit this
up because there's lots of great
resource
um you are gonna make web R successful
go build things and this is where you
can find me to learn more about this
I'll be back out there talk to people
about this I will talk your off about
Web Bar though so thank you